Fuller: So my name
is Alfred Fuller,
and this is Matt Wilder,
and we're gonna be talking
about how to get more 9's
with the high replication
datastore.
I'm a sophomore engineer on
the App Engine Datastore team,
Wilder: And I am
a site reliability engineer
on the App Engine team.
My focus is distributed storage.
So you may be asking yourself,
"Site reliability--
What is that?"
well, um, site reliability
is a position at Google
whose focus is the performance
and reliability
of Google services,
so if you'd like to know
a little bit more about that,
and what it's like running
App Engine in production,
um, I recommend that you attend
Alan Green and Michael Handler's
talk this afternoon, uh,
"Life In App Engine Production."
Fuller: And, uh, I can assume,
I think,
that you're all interested
in the datastore in general,
and if that's true, you should
check out past I/O talks,
name--specifically
the ones listed here
to get a better understanding
of how the datastore
works as a whole.
Today, though,
we're gonna talk about--
well, we're gonna give you a
brief overview of the datastore,
uh, highlighting the common
infrastructure components
that it actually uses,
talk about the datastore
in production,
highlighting specifically
common cases,
uh, planned maintenance,
and unplanned events,
then talk about
lessons learned, uh,
from running the datastore
for over three years now.
And then give you some tips
on how to, uh,
better acclimate to
the high replication datastore,
if you so wish.
So the master/slave--
um, so the datastore comes
in two flavors now--
the master/slave datastore
is what we launched with
in April of 2008.
It uses asynchronous replication
from a master to a slave,
uh, and all--
since it has a master,
all rights and reads
go to a master,
and then they're replicated
to a slave.
High replication,
on the other hand,
uh, was released this January,
and what it does
is it synchronously writes
to greater than two replicas,
and it has no master,
so it's true multi-homing,
in that you can read and write
from any replica.
Wilder: So, uh, in order
to understand, uh,
how the datastore works,
it's important to understand
what it's made of.
So, uh, the datastore
is not actually
one large monolithic
piece of software,
but it's rather the culmination
of many layers of distributed
storage architecture.
Lots of these layers
are actually common
to lots
of Google services.
So, uh, at the top
we have the datastore,
which you're all probably
familiar with.
Um, it provides
a schemeless storage
to App Engine applications,
and provides, uh, arguably,
one of the most advanced
query engines of any distributed
storage database out there.
So, uh, the datastore stores
its data directly in megastore,
um, so everything I'm gonna talk
about this layer and below
is actually a common piece
of Google infrastructure.
So megastore provides
a sort of SQL-like interface
to distributed storage.
Um, it, uh,
has a strict schema,
so you define tables
and things like that,
similar to an SQL database.
Um, it provides
multi-row transactions
that can actually span machines.
Um, where it's different
than a standard SQL database,
though, is its unit
of transactionality,
which is centered
around an entity group.
Um, Alfred will talk a little
bit more about that later.
Um, megastore stores its data
in Bigtable,
which many of you very well
may have heard of.
Um, Bigtable is, um, a large
distributed key value datastore.
Um, it's not a standard database
like you would think.
Um, you can store data
in, uh, columns,
and access them
via the row key only.
It's a very important piece
of the datastore,
we'll talk a little bit more
about it later,
and it's widely used
at Google.
Um, at the bottom, uh,
Bigtable stores its data
in Google's Next Generation
distributed file system,
which is our successor
to GFS.
Fuller: So you might
be asking yourself,
"What's an entity group?"
Because up until
the high replication datastore,
you didn't really have to care
that much.
Um, uh, what it is, is it's
a logical grouping of entities
through a parent/child
key relationship.
And how it functions is,
it's a unit of transactionality,
as Matt said, so transactions
can only read and write
to entities in
a single entity group.
So if I wanted
to change entities
in the blue entity group
and entities
in the green entity group,
there's no way
to do that atomically.
But if I want to do it just in
the blue or just in the green,
then you can perform
atomic transactions on those.
Um, and more importantly for
the high replication datastore
is the unit of consistency.
So entity groups enforce
strong serial consistency,
so what you, uh, what you get--
or what you put,
you will always get after--
uh, after that put,
and you will never see
part of a transaction.
You will either see
all of a transaction,
or none of a transaction.
Um, so here's an example
of entities
that are arranged in
a parent/child relationship.
So we have users,
we have photos,
and a child entity under photos
of comments,
so the photo owns
those comments,
their comment on the photos.
Uh, it's probably created
by the users.
Uh, and then we have documents
and, uh, revision history
for those documents,
and comments on those documents,
and a blog post,
which is like a combination
of photos and documents.
I'm sorry--picture--yeah,
I said that right--cool.
Uh, and has comments
on those, as well.
Um, so if we look at the entity
groups that are here,
we can see that there's these,
uh, boundaries
that are imposed
by these entity groups,
so you can operate
on the revision history
of a document atomically, um,
but if you wanted to change
a photo and a document
at the same time,
you'd actually have to do
two transactions to do that.
So there's some limitations
besides just these boundaries
on entity groups, um,
the biggest of which
is a throughput limitation,
so we say that you can get
at least one write per second.
In practice,
in high replication datastore,
you can get, uh, five to ten.
And what happens is
if five writes
come in all at the same time,
four of 'em die with
a concurrency exception
and one of 'em gets through,
so this is--it's rate limits,
uh, how quickly you can write
to these entity groups.
However, it's important
to keep in mind
that a write per second does not
mean an entity per second.
If you use batch puts
and transactions,
those all count
as a single write,
so you can get high entities
per second throughput
if you, um, fan in your writes
and do 'em in batches.
Another thing
it's important to note
is that these can be arbitrarily
large groups--
groupings of entities.
As Matt said, uh,
entity groups
can span multiple machines
and still enforce
that transactionality,
um, so we actually
have entity groups
with tens of millions
of entities in 'em,
and it's no degradation
to performance.
So here's another outline
of the same entities,
just, uh, arranged
slightly differently,
uh, taking into consideration
the limitations
of the entity group.
In this case, I've grouped
all of the comments
that a user makes
under the user,
so it's in his entity group.
And if I show you the entity
group, uh, boundaries here,
you can see that, um, blog posts
are separate from comments,
are separate from documents,
are separate from photos.
And the reason why this grouping
may be a better grouping,
given the limitations
of entity groups,
is that it's unlikely
for a user
to write to a comment greater
than one comment per second,
while a blog post,
if it gets popular,
or, you know,
uh, someone tweets it,
uh, could spike
in the comments,
um, and that--at those points,
you probably want to have
a higher write rate
than one entity per second.
So speaking of consistency, um,
this is a very important thing
to understand
about the difference
between the high replication
and the master/slave datastore--
um, pretty much, there's only
really one difference,
and this is, uh,
the eventual consistency
for non-ancestor queries.
These are queries
where the entity group
is not known ahead of time,
because the query spans
multiple entity groups,
so there's no way to enforce
that strong serial consistency
that an entity group provides.
An example of
a non-ancestor query,
um, is "Select star From Comment
where user I.D. equals user.Id."
This is what you
would have to use
in that first grouping
of entities
to find out all the comments
that a user has made.
However, in the second
grouping of entities,
you can use this, uh, query,
which is
"Select star From Comment
where ancestor is user.Key,"
and when you do this query,
you are guaranteed to see
all the most recent results.
So for a user,
this is very important,
because they want
to have consistency.
They put a comment, and you
redirect them to the page
that shows that comment,
and they really want to see
the comment they just put, or
they think your site's broken.
So let's see why
this is the case,
why this difference exists
between master/slave
and, uh,
the high replication datastore.
Um, and to do this, we have
to look at how reads and writes
operate in both systems
in the common case.
So for a write
in master/slave,
we write to the local replica,
which is the master,
and then we asynchronously
replicate that write
to the slave, so that when you
read from that local master,
you know the local master,
um, saw any writes
that have been accepted
by the system,
so you're guaranteed
to see that write.
And if we look at this,
this is, uh,
a very simplified layout
of one of these replicas
in a datacenter.
So we have Datacenter "A" that
is hosting your application,
and we have a Bigtable "A"
that is hosting your data.
And when the datastore--
you invoke a datastore write,
it'll write to Bigtable "A",
which is the local Bigtable
in this case, and the master,
and then that write will
asynchronously replicate
to Bigtable "B"
at some later point.
So it'll return to you
as soon as we write
to Bigtable "A."
When you do a read, that read
goes directly to Bigtable "A",
and we know that that has seen
any writes that have succeeded.
However, in
the high replication case,
this is slightly
more complicated.
Maybe not slightly--
it's pretty complicated.
Uh...
Wilder: [laughs]
Fuller: Um, so a write--
you write to at least
a majority of replicas,
and you do this in two phases,
and when you do this,
it means that a minority
of replicas
may not have gotten
that write synchronously.
Then we replicate asynchronously
any write that a replica
hasn't seen,
or we do it on demand
when you do the read.
Uh, we can update whatever
replica you're reading from
and force that strong
serial consistency.
Reads are slightly different,
as well.
What we will do is we'll read
from the fastest replica,
which is usually the local,
but can be another replica,
and we can catch up on demand.
So if the fastest replica
isn't up to date,
what we will actually do--
I think I have it in a--
Yeah, cool, I'll do it
in this one--
Um... [laughs]
so if Replica "A"
isn't actually caught up,
what we will do is we'll
actually fail over--
Hold on--
There it goes--
We'll read from
Replica "C" instead,
and wait for Replica "A"
to catch up,
and as soon as Replica "A"
is caught up,
we'll start reading
from Replica "A,"
and this is all done,
uh, on a sub-RPC level,
so in the middle of an RPC,
we can switch back,
and make sure you're always
getting the fastest reads.
Writes, um, are complicated,
as I said.
There's two phases.
The first phase is a Prepare--
whoops--wrong slide, hold on.
[chuckles]
They look idintical--
identical.
Uh, the first stage
is a "Prepare,"
and the second stage
is an "Accept,"
which actually sends out
the payload,
which is your entity to write.
And you can see that this write
is actually
talking across datacenters
to all replicas synchronously,
and as long as a majority
of these datacenters, uh,
have all your--
or--or accept that write,
then the write succeeds.
And you can see in master/slave,
I had one replica--
or one Bigtable that was dark,
and trying to indicate that
that had all the "data,"
and in high replication,
there's no guarantee
that any replica
has all your data
at any given time.
And another thing, uh,
that's important to note
about this slide is that, uh,
there's no master in this case,
so that we can run apps
in multiple datacenters,
so we can have an app
in Datacenter "B"
reading and writing, uh,
to--to these, uh, Bigtables,
and--
Ops--Oh, that's also
important, I guess.
[chuckles]
Sorry, this is--
Yeah, I should have made
a distinction on these slides.
Um, yes, so we can have them
going all at the same time,
and everyone's happy
and everyone
can see in consistent views.
And theoretically, um, if it
was just the datastore alone,
we could actually be talking
to the same entity group
and writing to the same
entity groups, and, uh,
you'd still have your
data integrity maintained.
So obviously,
it's--
the world's a little slightly
more complicated in
the high replication datastore,
and if we look at the latencies,
this is reflected.
Um, we look
at the read latencies,
and you can see
that we've optimized
the high replication datastore
for reads.
In most cases,
it's almost identical
to what happens in
the master/slave datastore,
so the average read latency
is identical.
The write latency, on
the other hand, is, uh, higher,
um, because we have to do this
cross-datacenter
synchronous replication, um,
and we have to talk
to at least a majority,
uh, we have
additional latency here,
and it's also
two round trips,
um, so we have about twice
the amount of latency.
However, where
the high replication datastore
really shines is in its, uh,
error rates.
So if we look at these
average error rates,
and we look at the master/slave
error rate,
we can see that this .1%,
uh, error rate
is actually 3 9's, which
is the purpose of this talk,
is trying to get
more of these 9's,
and it's the common terminology
when we talk about it in SLA,
which is
a service level agreement.
So in this case,
3 9's actually means
that your datastore is down
for 8.7 hours a year.
And I'm not taking
into consideration here
planned maintenance
or catastrophic failures.
This is the ambient error rate
that you can expect
with the master/slave datastore.
With a high replication
datastore, on the other hand,
you can see
that we actually have 5 9's,
which is many more 9's,
especially when you take into
consideration its impact, uh...
[clears throat]
uh, which is 5 minutes a year
as opposed to almost 9 hours
of downtime
in times of ambient error rates.
Wilder: So let's talk about how
these two datastores differ
in some of
the less common cases.
The first one we're gonna talk
about is planned maintenance.
So Google datacenters undergo
planned maintenance periods.
During these periods,
low-level pieces
of the common infrastructure,
such as networking,
power, cooling,
maybe low-level
cluster management,
distributed storage services
are--undergo maintenances
that require a downtime
to accomplish.
Most Google services,
including App Engine,
are able to do
in-place upgrades.
So, you know, we can
upgrade our software,
and your app
doesn't know about it.
However, with low-level things
like power,
it's kind of hard to do that.
Um, so, you know, kind of hard
to turn off machines one by one,
and, you know,
do things like that.
So, uh, Google groups these,
uh, upgrades
into contiguous time periods.
That way, you know, all of these
sort of chaotic maintenances
can happen at the datacenter
at the same time
or as close to the same time
as possible.
So when these cases
are happening, you know,
a datacenter can be offline
for several days,
um, depending upon the type
of maintenance.
So what does this look like
for master/slave datastore?
Um, so when one of these
maintenance periods
happens to the datacenter
that we're serving master/slave
applications out of,
we don't want those applications
to be offline for several days
while these maintenances
are performed.
So we need to switch
which datacenter
is currently the master and
which one is the slave.
To do this, we perform what we
call a master switch operation.
Um, this operation
involves about one hour
of read-only datastore,
and it's a fairly complicated
semi-automatic procedure
that requires a member
of the engineering team
to execute a very specific set
of steps to accomplish.
Um, a lot of these steps
depend on other Google services
and pieces of
internal infrastructure.
Um, if those services
aren't working well
or they're experiencing
unavailability,
it can cause us
to slow down our process,
and it can make us miss
the maintenance window
that we tell you about
in advance
or make us be read-only longer
than we want to.
So, um, we work hard
to make sure
that we catch these things
in advance,
so that if we do find them,
we will cancel
the maintenance period
and move it
to another time period.
And we try to improve
the process as much as we can.
Fuller: So let's see
what this looks like,
uh, given that diagram
that I showed you earlier.
So we have an app that's reading
and writing to Bigtable "A"
and replicating to Bigtable "B".
And we are notified of
a planned maintenance period,
and we notify you, in turn,
that we're gonna take your app
into read-only.
And then during the window,
we initiate a read-only period,
so that your app can still read,
but it cannot write.
Then we flush the replication
of anything that hasn't been
replicated yet
to make sure that Bigtable "A"
and Bigtable "B"
both have identical information
and all of the most
up-to-date information.
Then we drain Datacenter "A"
into Datacenter "B,"
and we switch the master
and the slave.
During this period, since they
contain, uh, both information,
your app experiences
no interruption
in read-only service,
uh, so they can both read,
'cause they're gonna see
the same data.
As soon as we've completed
that drain,
we can enable the writing
to your app.
So now you're reading
from Bigtable "B",
and you're writing
to Bigtable "B,"
and then "A" synchronously
replicating to Bigtable "A".
And at this point,
there's no guarantee
that Bigtable "A"
has all of the data,
thus is now the slave.
Wilder: So what happens to
high replication applications
when we have one of these
maintenance periods?
Um, they're pretty much,
uh, not affected at all.
Um, while we do still
primarily serve
high replication applications
out of a single datacenter,
which we'll talk a little bit
more about why in a minute,
we're able to seamlessly migrate
these applications
from one datacenter to another
without almost any notice
to the developer
or the user of the application.
Um, furthermore,
we're able to do this
without any interaction
from the app engine team at all.
None of our team
has to initiate this process.
The reason why we can do this
is that Google datacenters
have a system for notifying
services running within them
that these maintenance periods
are beginning,
and they should move their
traffic out of that datacenter.
So when App Engine
receives this signal,
we automatically move
the application
serving in that datacenter
to another one
that's not gonna go under one
of these maintenance periods
anytime soon.
As I said, this switching
is almost transparent.
Um, what is noticeable
is a flush of Memcache
at approximately one minute
where you can read
from Memcache,
but it's always empty,
and you can write,
and it just pretends to succeed.
The reason that this is the case
is that we--
and the primary reason why we
only serve HR applications
out of a single datacenter
is that--is Memcache
is a very fast API,
you know?
If you've used it, you get
requests and responses back
in, like, in order
of milliseconds.
Um, that's because we don't
replicate it
to the other datacenters
we serve your higher
applications applications from.
If we did, um, the time
it would take that data
to transmit
to those other datacenters
would make Memcache
a very slow API
and not as useful for what
you probably use it for.
Unfortunately, even Google is
limited by the speed of light.
Fuller: So let's see
what that looks like
in the high replication.
So we get a signal
from our infrastructure team,
and our system automatically
drains apps from Datacenter "A"
and serves them
out of Datacenter "B."
And then the infrastructure team
takes down to the Bigtable
and Datacenter "A,"
so it's unavailable.
And when we do a read,
we read from Bigtable "B".
And when we do a write,
we write to a majority.
And in this case,
you can see that Bigtable "A"
is not responding
to any of our writes,
but the write still succeeds,
because we have a majority
of replicas still responding
to our write.
Wilder: So, uh, let's talk
about some other reasons
why the 9's and the datastores
are different.
Um, uh, no distributed
storage system is perfect.
Google is no exception.
Um, we do have unplanned issues.
Um, we tend to group
these issues
into two primary categories--
global and local failures.
So we're gonna talk
about local failures first.
Um, we, at Google,
group local failures
into two other
various categories--
expected and unexpected.
So it may sound a little strange
that we have unplanned
expected failures,
but in reality,
they're a fundamental part
of storage Google.
The primary reason for this
is Bigtable.
Um, as I said before, Bigtable
is a very important part
of the datastore storage stack.
It's also a very widely used,
important piece of software
at Google.
Bigtable is a very amazing piece
of software.
It's able to scale
to incredibly large size.
It can have an un--mind-boggling
amounts of data in it,
and it can support huge amounts
of transactions per second,
reads, and writes.
And it can span many, many,
many, many machines.
Well, in order
to make this possible,
the designers of Bigtable
made some trade-offs
that result in data
being unavailable
for short periods of time.
Here's why--
Um, at its core,
Bigtable splits its data up
into contiguous blocks
called tablets.
Um, these tablets
are made available
by a process that's called
tablet servers.
So every Bigtable cell
has a lot of tablet servers,
and each tablet server
has a lot of tablets loaded.
Now these tablets
can only sustain
a certain threshold
of reads and writes.
If they get more reads
and writes than that,
then performance
will be degraded.
So Bigtable responds to this
by splitting that tablet into
two or more smaller tablets.
And if the tablet server
serving those tablets
is experiencing too much load,
it will move those tablets
to another tablet server,
which is less--less loaded.
Now while these operations
are happening,
um, the data is unavailable
for that period of time.
Now these operations
are supposed to be very fast,
but occasionally, they are slow.
This is one of
the most common causes
of unexpected local issues.
Um, occasionally,
something causes these split
or merge operations to be slow.
Um, one example
that we have noticed
is a tablet server
is on a machine
that's maybe unhealthy,
or something is causing it
to perform poorly.
If this is happening,
requests to this tablet server
will be slower,
and maybe those split operations
aren't happening as fast
as they should be.
Another example of reasons
that we have seen
this performance happen
is due to the distributed
file system underneath.
When those tablets move
to other tablet servers,
um, the new tablet server
needs to load that tablet
off of Google's distributed
file system.
If for some reason
that operation is slow,
then the data is unavailable
for longer
while the tablet server
is trying to load that data
to make it available again.
One of the most causes of this
happening is isolation.
As I said,
Bigtable and Google's
distributed file system
are pieces of
common infrastructure.
So multiple users
of the datacenter
use the same instants.
While isolation has been
built in from the ground up,
it's not perfect.
Isolation on distributed
storage systems of this scale
is a--is a very hard problem
to solve.
So what do these issues,
uh, look like
for applications that you use
in master/slave datastore?
Well, as Alfred said,
um, applications that use
master/slave datastore
depend upon a single Bigtable
to be available
to support those reads
and writes.
So if that Bigtable
is experiencing these
unavailability issues,
then those translate directly
into unavailability
with the datastore.
Um, as I said,
the type of availability we're
talking about here is local,
which means it only affects
small portions of data,
which means
that some applications
may be completely unaffected,
and some applications
may be affected.
What does this look like?
Um, the most common thing
that this will present itself
to its users
is those random
deadline exceeded errors
that you'll see in your
application's error logs.
Typically in the stack trace,
you may see a datastore RPC
or something like that.
If the problem persists
for a long time,
requests can back up
in your request queue,
and it can actually begin
to affect requests
that don't actually involve
the datastore.
If you have
a master/slave application,
you may have experienced this
on availability,
and you may have noticed
that maybe this App Engine
status site
doesn't display that their
datastore is having any issues.
The reason for this
is that at its core,
the App Engine status site
currently uses
actual applications
to monitor the health
of the various APIs
and present them
on the status site.
So if those applications
aren't being affected
by this local unavailability,
it may not show up
on the status site,
despite the fact
that it's affecting you.
It's important to note
that our internal monitoring
does catch these issues,
and when they happen,
we are notified,
and the on-call engineering team
will respond to them
as quickly as we possibly can.
We're also working on improving
the status site
to better catch and report
these type of issues.
Fuller: So let's look
at what this looks like.
So your application tries to do
a read, and it fails.
We try to do a write,
and it fails.
We just get no response.
We retry this,
and eventually, it times out.
However, there is one thing
that you can do
to improve the scenario
in your application's case,
which is to enable
eventually consistent reads.
In this case, what will happen
is your application will try
to read, which will fail,
and then it will read
from the slave instance,
which may have stale data,
but in some cases,
that's acceptable.
In these cases, we recommend
that you enable this
if you're gonna use
master/slave.
Wilder: So how do these issues
affect applications
that use
the high replication datastore?
In short,
they have no impact at all.
As we've mentioned,
high replication applications
don't depend on the health
of a single Bigtable cell
in order to perform.
So if the local Bigtable
to your application
is experiencing these problems,
requests will seamlessly
fail over to another Bigtable,
and this happens on
a per-request basis
with no interaction
from anyone whatsoever.
Fuller: I should point out
that I made the tech lead
of Megastore,
which is--
He's one of the masterminds
behind the paxos implementation
that runs
the high replication datastore,
posed for this picture.
Um, so let's see what this
looks like.
So we have local failures,
your app tries to do a read
from Bigtable "A",
and it'll immediately fail over
to Bigtable "C"
without any loss of consistency,
and it can do this
because we're operating
on entity groups.
And if Bigtable "C" doesn't have
the most current data,
it can on demand
replicate that data.
And, in fact,
when we do this operation,
we'll look at all the replicas
and see which one does have
the data and prefer that one,
so we don't actually have
to block on the catch-up
that has to happen in a replica
that doesn't have that data.
When we do a write, it simply
doesn't affect the algorithm
because we only require
a majority in these cases.
So you don't see
any user visible effect.
And eventually, since we track
the health of these Bigtables,
uh, the health tracker
will decide that Bigtable "A"
is either slow
or being unavailable,
and it won't even try
to read from it.
It will actually just read
from another replica
that is the fastest replica
to serve your writes.
And eventually,
this error will go away
and will switch back to reading
from the local replica,
as it is usually the fastest.
Wilder: So let's talk about
failures on a global level.
Um, these are the type
of failures
that render
an entire datacenter
either offline or unusable.
Some of the examples
of the causes
of these types of errors is--
Let's say the fiber-optic cables
connecting the datacenter
of the network get cut,
or there's a power outage,
and the backup generators fail,
powering off the datacenter.
Maybe there's some bug
or major issue
with, you know, lower-level
pieces of the infrastructure
that just render the datacenter
completely kaput,
completely useless.
Google's datacenters
are really big,
so when these sort
of things happen,
it tends to take a long time
to recover.
If we power off an entire
datacenter, for example,
you know, turning all
those machines back on
and making sure
all the machines turn up
and check their disks
if necessary
and start up
all those processes,
it takes a long time
on Google's scale.
Furthermore, you know,
if fiber-optic cables get cut--
I don't know if any of you have
ever experienced this--
it takes a long time
to get those tables repaired.
So these things take
the datacenter offline
for quite some time.
Fuller: Now although this is
unfortunate when this happens,
they do make great stories.
So I will again plug Handler's
talk that comes after this.
Wilder: So what effect
do these outages happen
on master/slave applications?
Well, as you can probably guess,
if that datacenter that we're
serving at disappears,
the applications disappear, too.
It's important to note
in this case
that with global failures,
it typically is not just
a datastore that goes offline.
But if it's like a power outage
or networking,
the whole app engine
serving stack goes away,
which means that it's not
just the datastore
that's unavailable,
but your whole application
is unavailable.
So what do we do about this?
Well, when this happens, we
perform an emergency failover.
This is an emergency
switch operation
so we can just
switch applications
to serve out
of the other datacenter.
Now master/slave
uses an asynchronous
replication scheme.
So if we do an emergency switch,
there's gonna be some data loss
on a temporary level.
Now this data loss presents
itself in two primary ways.
One is just unreplicated data.
This is data that was written
to the master
and never replicated over
when that master datacenter
went offline.
So this data is just missing
until that datacenter comes
back, and we can recover it.
Another type is partially
replicated data.
This is when the data
was written to the master
and was in the process of being
replicated to the slave
when the datacenter
went offline,
and we performed
this emergency failover.
In this case, when we have part
of a transaction applied
or part of an update made,
and the datastore knows
that it's missing this data,
and so it does not allow writes
to this data
until it receives the rest of
that transaction or that update.
Now as I said before,
this datacenter may be offline
for a while,
so we don't want to wait
for that datacenter to come back
to finish that write.
So what we do is once we finish
this emergency procedure,
we then go through and check
the entire datastore
for any instance of this, uh,
this partially replicated data,
and we manually roll back
those transactions,
making your data
available again.
Now eventually,
this other datacenter
does come back online,
and that Bigtable comes back
with it.
At this point,
we have data in that Bigtable
that was not replicated over.
However, we can't just replicate
that data now,
because you may have written
to that data since
or deleted it or something,
and so there would be
a conflict.
So instead, what we do
is we dump the data out
of that Bigtable
and provide it to the developers
on an offline basis,
so they can decide
what they think is best to do.
Fuller: So let's look
at what this emergency failover
looks like.
Reads and writes are failing,
and then we decide
that Bigtable "A'
is probably gonna be down
for a while,
and it would be much better
for our users
to have our sites active.
Um, and so we initiate
an emergency failover,
which just force-swaps
the master and the slave.
And as you can see, Bigtable "B"
hasn't had
its replication flushed,
thus does not have all the data.
And as Matt said, that data
is still durable
and in Bigtable "A,"
so we can recover it later.
But the more important thing is
to get your apps running again,
so now this app is, uh,
reading and writing
from Bigtable "B."
Wilder: So what effect do
these global failures have
on applications that use
the high replication datastore?
Well, as I said before,
they do primarily serve out
of a single datacenter,
so when we have these major
global failures,
there is a slight bit
of unavailability,
but they recover within minutes,
and there is absolutely
no data loss.
The reason why they are able
to recover so quickly
is you remember that system
I talked about
when we do planned maintenance
where the infrastructure can
notify users of that datacenter
that the datacenter is going
offline for maintenance?
Well, when these
global failures happen
that take
the datacenter offline,
the same system is used
to notify those services
that, hey,
an emergency has happened.
This datacenter is unusable.
Move your traffic now.
So when we get that signal,
just like with
the planned maintenance,
we seamlessly migrate
the applications
to serve out
of another datacenter.
Um, data is written
to more than one Bigtable
with high replication datastore,
which means that we haven't lost
any data at all.
Furthermore, due
to the masterless nature
of the high replication
datastore,
we actually provision
each application,
so that they can lose
multiple datacenters
and still serve normally.
This means that if
the datacenter is offline
for a really long time due
to a tornado or a fire
or an alien invasion
or something like that,
your application
can still experience
any of the type of failures that
I've talked about right now
and not experience
any unavailability.
Fuller: So this slide
should be familiar,
because it's exactly the same
as a planned failover,
which is important to notice.
If your application--
if the global failure just
affects the durability layer,
you will see that the adaptation
will still serve
and will still
read and write successfully,
because we can always use--
not use Bigtable "A".
If it does affect
the entire stack,
and even when it just affects
the Bigtable,
the infrastructure team,
as Matt said,
will notify
our automated system,
which will do a drain,
and now your app is serving out
of Datacenter "B."
And so it's important to note
that unplanned failures
have the exact same effect
as planned ones
in the high replication
datastore.
So they--they're as Matt said,
your data is maintained.
The consistency is there,
and your application sees
very little downtime, if any.
Wilder: So what lessons
have we learned
from three years of running
the App Engine
master/slave datastore
and building the high
replication datastore?
First is expect the unexpected.
Global failures--you don't
expect them to happen,
but they do happen.
They've happened a few times
to App Engine in the past,
and they will probably
someday happen again.
Another is that the improbable
is probable
when you're dealing with a scale
of Google.
Errors that have
an incredibly small chance
of happening, say,
memory corruption or CPU bugs,
things like that,
happen on a regular basis
when you're dealing with systems
of this scale,
and you have to think
about them.
Otherwise, they're gonna
really bite you.
Fuller: Another thing
we've, um, heard
from feedback from our users
is that consistent performance
is typically better
than low latency,
because low latency
plus inconsistent performance
is not something
you can plan for.
Uh, typically, applications that
are built in the master/slave
expect the consistent behavior
that they experience
when they test
their applications.
And when you experience
these local failures,
you will get random
deadlines exceeded,
and it will kind of
speckle through--
those errors will speckle
through all your request logs.
And one important thing
that we've actually heard back
from developers
is that if they know the latency
is gonna be slower
yet consistent, they can
typically program around that
and make accommodations
for that,
so consistency is generally
better in these cases.
Wilder: So another thing
is the more that we can
automatically handle failures,
the less downtime we have
for our users
and the less work
we have operationally
to keep the service running.
A human being is a lot slower
at pushing a button
responding to an event
than a computer is.
And if the computer can respond
to that event
by failing over or doing
something to avoid the error
that's happened, um, seamlessly,
then we can hide that error
from our users
and present
a consistent experience.
Fuller: And another benefit
of this
is that we can focus on more
features for our developers,
such as Next Gen queries,
if any of you remember that talk
from last year.
I don't know.
[laughs]
Um, and one thing
we really notice
is that unavailability
is never good.
Small percentages
at Google scales
have a big impact
on--on many apps,
um, so that when these
local failures happen,
they typically affect,
uh, an app
to a large degree,
even though it doesn't affect
the entire cluster.
And these types of problems--
well, they're important to us
to fix,
because we want every app
to--to have a good experience
on App Engine,
and we hope that the master--
the high replication datastore
will address these issues.
So as a recap,
the high replication datastore
is, uh,
has a slightly higher
write latency,
is slightly less
globally consistent,
which is in that one case
of global queries,
um, and it--but it's
incredibly fault-tolerant.
So we have designed it to be
geographically distributed,
and it's resilient in the face
of catastrophic failure.
And we think that, uh, it will
get you a lot more 9's.
And, uh, from--since launch,
we actually--we really believe
this so much
that we're gonna set it
as a default
as we announced yesterday,
and we're also
lowering the price
to match that of master/slave,
'cause we really feel strongly
in this product.
[applause]
Wilder: So what's next?
Um, well, we may
have convinced you
to use the high replication
datastore with this talk.
And you may have an application
and say "Wow, this is great.
"Well, I have
a master/slave application.
I want to migrate to
the high replication datastore."
So we have a procedure
for doing this now.
It requires a read-only period
while we copy your data
from the master/slave datastore
to the high replication
datastore.
This can be slightly less ideal
for applications that have
a large amount of data.
So we're really hard at work
on some new migration tools
that will dramatically
improve this
and dramatically reduce
the amount of read-only period
you will need to migrate
your application,
and you can expect those
to come out really soon.
Fuller: So that being said,
that we want you
to migrate over,
and we think it's better
for everyone,
let's talk about
what you have to do to--
in terms of your app's logic to
deal with eventual consistency
that you see in global queries.
So the first thing you have
to do is a code audit
for all global queries, queries
without ancestors in them,
um, 'cause everything else
is strongly consistent,
and you can rely on that it will
operate the exact same way
it's operated before in
the master/slave datastore.
And these global queries
that you look for
shouldn't just be the ones that
are immediately after a put,
because when you have
change requests,
like in a user experience
and you put something
in one request,
and you go to the next request,
the user usually expects
what they have written
to show up immediately.
So there are many ways to handle
this situation
once you find these queries.
The first one that I would
suggest is accept it.
There are a lot of queries that
don't need strong consistency.
When you have a write rate
that is incredibly high,
that it doesn't support
a single entity group,
in these cases,
if you don't see the last
hundred milliseconds to seconds,
which is the type of eventual
consistency we're talking about
with a high replication
datastore,
it's not as important.
So if you have a Twitter stream
come flooding into your app,
in these cases, eventual
consistency is acceptable.
Another thing you can do
is avoid it,
so you can isolate the cases
where you actually can,
um, have this limit
of the write rate
for the entity groups
and build larger entity groups,
'cause entity group size
can be arbitrarily big.
So as long as you trickle it in,
you don't have to worry about,
uh, you know,
getting over that, uh,
you know, how big your
entity group actually is.
Now one of the most interesting
things you can do,
um, is work around it.
And you can do this
by mixing datastore results.
So in that example
I showed you previously
where the comments were
clustered under the user
and we had the blog post
that was separate--
in a separate entity group,
if I wanted to show a user
the comments from a blog post,
I would actually perform
two queries.
One query would be
a strongly consistent query
that has the user
as an ancestor,
so it gives me all
of the user's comments.
And I know I see most or all
of the user's comments
that he's posted,
and the other one that grabs
everyone else's comments,
because it's really important
that the user sees
his own comments.
But if he doesn't see the last--
the comments that were posted
in the last hundred
milliseconds,
it's not that big of a deal
in these situations.
So you really have to look
at your app
and decide what one of
these methods do you use where.
Another option here
is you can use Memcache
to store writes
to have a write cache
and inject those into
your datastore query results,
as well.
So that's it.
Um, we're open for questions.
[applause]
Wilder: I guess it's
the front mic. I don't know.
Fuller: Yeah. Robert.
Robert: So about Next Gen--No.
Wilder: [laughs]
Robert: Um, so I have
a hopefully easy question.
If you do a batch get
across entity groups,
and you do it
with eventually consistent--
you know, if you set up the RPC
eventually consistent,
will that cause the tablet
that winds up getting hit
to catch up if it's late?
So it'll--I know it'll fetch
and return what's there.
Fuller: Yeah.
Robert: But does it initiate
the catch-up sequence
in the background?
Fuller: So you--you still
have a benefit of doing
eventually consistent reads
in the high replication
datastore.
It will not catch up
the replica, and always just
pick the fastest in that case.
Robert: Okay.
Fuller: So you're guaranteed
to have a little boost
in many cases. Uh--
Wilder: The reason for this
is that we don't know
what the entity group is
if it's spanning entity groups.
Fuller: Oh, this
is different, though.
Wilder: Oh, sorry. [chuckles]
Fuller: So yeah.
This is for batch gets. Yeah.
Wilder: Batch get, oh, okay.
Robert: Yes. Yep. Okay, cool.
Wilder: Thanks.
man: Is there any information
or ways to control
where the data goes
and especially for the case
of Megastore,
if you start running paxos
across, say,
the Atlantic Ocean,
um...
Wilder: So we--we don't
currently offer
any sort of um,
uh, different geographic
distributions for our data.
man: Okay, so it runs
in a single datacenter?
Fuller: No.
Wilder: No. So we have one set
of specifics...
Fuller: Ev--
Wilder: One geographic set
of distributed data bases--
or datacenters, but we don't
offer any sort of locality.
Fuller: So we--they each run
in a different datacenter,
and all datacenters are
currently in North America.
man: Okay.
Wilder: Yeah, right.
Fuller: But if you want
to have fast operations
in other places,
you should use caching headers.
man: Okay, thanks.
man: One question I had.
Wilder: Oh, go ahead.
man: When you mentioned
about the tablets
and how it stores the data in
the tablets and splits that,
what's the decision path
about what data gets stored
in what tablet where
and how does it know
what tablet to go get it from?
Wilder: So all this is built
into Bigtable, basically.
Fuller: [whispers]
Repeat the question.
Wilder: Oh, the question was,
How does the tablet logic work?
How does it know where to fetch
the data and when to split,
stuff like that?
So it's all part
of the Bigtable service.
Um, there's many data
and things involved,
uh, that is updated
when these things happen,
which is part of the reason why
there's brief unavailability,
is because the tablet moves,
and certain things
have to be updated,
and that takes just a little bit
of time to happen.
man: So is it like a hash off of
the key or something like that?
Wilder: I can't
really comment much
on the specific implementation.
man: Okay, thanks.
Fuller: [normal voice]
There's some Bigtable papers.
I don't know if they actually go
into that much detail,
but they're a nice read...
Wilder: Yeah.
Fuller: If you're
really interested
in that level.
man: Okay.
Fuller: There's also a Megastore
paper that is very accessible,
and I would really recommend
anyone who is interested
in the exact details
of this algorithm--
This was a very, uh,
glossed overview
of what actually happens
in terms of writes.
And so if you're interested,
I highly recommend checking out
that paper.
man: For the, uh,
high replication datastore
writing to the majority
of datacenters,
how many datacenters
are we talking about?
Is that something...
Wilder: More than two.
Fuller: So we--we can't tell you
the exact numbers...
man: Yeah.
Fuller: But it's more than two,
and we can withstand multiple
datacenters going down.
man: Right.
man: I think it's also--
it's an odd number, right?
Wilder: Yes, it is
an odd number. Yeah.
[laughter]
Wilder: It's hard to have a
majority without an odd number.
man: Um, I wanted to ask
about the, uh, entity groups.
Is there a prac--
What are the practical limits
on how big an entity group
could be?
I mean, from what you described,
it sounds like
you can just throw everything
into one entity group...
Fuller: Yes, it--
man: And obviously,
that's probably not wise.
And do those,
uh, limitations change
with the high replication
datastore?
Fuller: So the limitation
is just on throughput.
And J.J.,
uh, the picture I showed
of the guy who actually designed
entity groups
and was kind of the mastermind
behind that
would suggest to you
that you put all your entities
and an application
into a single entity group.
Now we want your application
to scale.
If you get hit
really hard with traffic,
and that's good for you
and good for us,
so we won't make that exact
same recommendation.
But if you're expecting
a write rate
of less than one write per
second for your app forever--
say it's an Enterprise app--
you can definitely put
all of your data
into a single entity group.
Fuller: Okay.
man: One question
about the, uh,
high replication strategy.
So how can you decide the global
order for the transaction
if the transaction comes through
different server--
I mean, the, no,
in the cluster?
Fuller: So the question is, uh,
How can we decide the global
order of transactions
if they come in
from multiple servers?
man: Yes. Uh, yes.
Fuller: Yeah, okay.
She told me
to repeat the question...
[laughter]
Fuller: Even though
you're miked.
Um, uh, so, um, before you--
So we use optimistic locking,
right?
So what happens is
the transaction will start
on both, uh, replicas,
but only one will succeed if
they're happening concurrently.
So the serial consistency
is enforced
in that we know that only one
can s--can--can--
succeed in this case.
And we use optimistic locking,
because someone who starts
a transaction may die
or may stop or may never
complete it or may take forever,
so that we know that we can push
writes through
even in the case of failure
or long--
Like if we use
pessimistic locking,
you would have to wait
for the lock to expire
if the writer disappears, so we
use this for fault tolerance,
and it also makes it
so that it works well.
man: So this part...
[speaking indistinctly]
or it's...
Wilder: It's part
of a Megastore.
Fuller: So the--
So the Prepare and Accept...
man: Mm-hmm.
Fuller: is what happened,
how it gets around.
So if you prepare,
and then someone else prepares,
they, um, they overwrite
your prepare.
And if you try to get everyone
who agreed to your prepare
to accept,
you'll get rejected.
And then we have a backoff
to make sure that this pattern
doesn't keep on going,
because the next thing you do
is you try to prepare again.
So you fight back and forth,
and there's a backoff
to make sure that this doesn't
go on forever,
and someone eventually wins.
man: Thank you.
man: I have a question about
the performance limitation
of tablet splitting
when you have them autonomically
increasing indexed value,
like a date time stamp.
Is that less of a problem with
the high replication datastore
than the master/slave?
Fuller: Um, I--yes.
It's still a problem.
So the question is,
is when you're writing
to the same spot in a table--
uh, say I'm autonomically
increasing index
based on a time stamp--
That creates a hot spot
on the table,
and the tablet can only split
in the existing data
that it has,
and the smallest it can split
is a single row.
So if you write to a row,
a lot of times,
you would have a hot spot
that you can actually split.
But this will limit your
write rate in master/slave
to empirically about 200 writes
per second
to that spot in that index.
Um, and it's a problem
that Bigtable
can't really resolve for you.
Um, and so the master/slave--
what would happen in this case
is those writes would fail
in one datacenter
that's getting a lot of traffic,
and then that traffic
would bleed over
to the other datacenters
where the write wouldn't fail,
because the asynchronous
replication
isn't hammering it as hard.
So in this case, it will help,
but it will not solve
the problem.
To really solve that problem,
you have to use some sort
of sharding on that index
to make it, uh, split
among different tablets.
Wilder: Yeah, it'll help
for a while, but eventually,
all of the replicas
will have this same problem.
And so you're
just kind of delaying
the inevitable, basically.
Fuller: But, you know, you get
up to 400 instead of 200...
Wilder: Yeah. [chuckles]
Fuller: or 600 instead of 200,
but I don't know
the exact numbers,
and the numbers
that I am saying right now
are definitely empirical
that I heard from Brett Slatkin
who runs PubSubHubbub.
man: [chuckles]
man: All right, thank you.
Fuller: Yeah.
man: Um, along the same lines
of the guy asking about entity
groups and recommendations,
do you guys
have any documentation
about, um, the best use
of entity groups
or any recommendations
about how to group your data,
um, aside from coming
to Google I/O
or watching the videos?
'Cause that's the only place
I've been able to find it
in the past.
Fuller: I think
that's a very good point.
I think we should improve
our documentation around this,
and I know that, um, we are--
There's several people who are
try to do that internally.
The Megastore paper
is a good resource,
and my recommendation would be
to look at the throughput
you need and base it on that.
And usually, well,
you can think about this
is a lot of micro databases.
Each entity group
is like a micro database.
and so from the example I gave,
the micro database is based
around a user, right?
So where the user really cares
about that consistency,
whereas the interactions
between you--
there can be a little less.
Uh...
You know, it can get a little
looser around that consistency,
so...
Oh, and Anderson?
Wilder: Dan Sanderson.
Fuller: Sanderson. Yeah,
Dan Sanderon's App Engine book
apparently goes into talking
about this, as well.
man: Yeah, I have some question
about this writing part.
Fuller: Mm-hmm.
man: Uh, I read
those Google file systems,
and they usually--
when you write, usually
they kind of serial write.
When you write one,
and then they will just write
replica each other like that.
When I see your,
uh, presentation,
it looks like one
write application
talk to all the replica
at the same time.
Is it like do you change it,
or you are using some kind of
group communication to do that?
Or is it just the serial still?
Fuller: We use--
we write asynchronous--
Or we write in parallel
to multiple datacenters...
man: Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Fuller: Using
inter datacenter band width.
So we go around
these boundaries,
but inside the datacenter
is probably--
I can't really speak to it.
man: But usually in datacenter,
they have closer locality,
right?
so I saw in Google...
[indistinct] version 1,
they're just using
one close replica,
and then that replica will find
their neighbors, like that.
Fuller: Yeah, so--
man: And then the final
will return, say,
everything complete.
That was what I understood,
but is it--
Fuller: So that would happen
inside a single datacenter,
but we--we write to multiple
of them, right?
man: Yeah, but, I mean--
Fuller: So on that level,
I don't know exactly how it
works, but it sounds reasonable.
man: Yeah, so I was just
wondering if you change it
or if you change it,
then the underlying should be
a lot of different things
need to be done.
Fuller: Yeah, so, um...
Wilder: So the underlying stuff
is a little bit different,
um, but, um,
we haven't really released
any information
about how it's different,
so I can't really comment much.
Fuller: Yeah.
man: Yeah, but I read some paper
about this Google file system
you've probably seen.
Fuller: Yeah. So we're using
another version of that
that's similar but not the same.
Wilder: The primary difference
that we've actually talked about
is that the original one
had a single master,
and this one has multi master.
man: Okay.
Wilder: That's
the primary difference.
man: Yeah, okay. Thank you.
Fuller: Any more questions?
Fuller: Well, I guess that's it.
Well, thank you all for coming.
[applause]
Wilder: THANK YOU.